retro games are very much on vogue at
this year's international games week in
Berlin operating techniques are
rudimentary and the graphics are archaic
but gamers here put body and soul into
them berlin game developers riyadh jimmy
lee and johannes chrisman love the 30
year old games they're fascinated by
pac-man and other classics of the genre
this reason I just moobus to kumon it's
like old furniture that you wouldn't
ever put in your living room nowadays
because it's cumbersome or weighs a ton
albumen but you still admire it for the
craftsmanship that went into effect in
kunst behind closeness they both
recently gave up their jobs with a major
games developer to start their own
studio their first creation was the
curious expedition a game of strategy
it's brand new but looks like a relic of
the 1990s the setting is the 1800s the
player heads an expedition off to
explore distant lands and overcome all
sorts of obstacles such as strange never
before contacted people's
or natural disasters Johannes christmann
designs the old school graphics he
conjures up landscapes using just a
handful of pixels the game's simple no
frills look is another advantage
undisputed mr. snail our game won't be
outdated too quickly because it was
designed to be an antique antique full
house also we hope it'll still be
playable in five or ten years time in
contrast when the modern game comes out
today it already looks outdated after
six months plus there's a reduction of
the resolution which we hope will leave
more to the players imagination orphaned
Estefan desi discreet us all of my mia
home became that the games concept is
also influenced by the classics as in
the original adventure games the player
has to read a lot and carry out
complicated tasks if your character dies
you have to start all over again with no
saving your previous progress this isn't
connecting dispute the tricky game that
can make you tear your hair out for a
few hours that too is reminiscent of the
old difficult games there's a great
fascination with a game that's hard to
master and in which you can fail to
fight up in our game there were lots of
ways to lose and that's a big attraction
will hide retro that's what people
usually call games that are more than 20
years old this is the mother of all
commercial computer games pong from the
year nineteen seventy to a little later
space invaders came out it paved the way
for a series of other shoot-'em-up games
mario appeared in 1983 and made jump and
run games popular around the world then
came the first graphic adventure games
Monkey Island from 1990 boasted
outstanding graphics and a cult
following today more and more developers
are out to return to the old look
as in Minecraft from 2009 with 56
million copies sold it's one of the most
successful games in the world despite or
maybe precisely because of its graphics
gaming expert andreas langa says those
images remind many people of their youth
these are fluent computers these early
computer games became popular at the
time when computer technology as a whole
was spreading these graphics became
known along with the first personal
computers with your 15 I'm looking back
today we know how important this
development was for us it's the only
damage a digital revolution began back
then and so these retro graphics don't
stand just for dumb old games but for
computer technology as a computer taking
the in schism and retro games are
popping up in art to 8-bit graphics on
canvas here at Berlin games a week the
game boy is obviously still a huge
favorite and among the eye catchers at
the exhibition as is the Nintendo family
of figures the past inspiring the
present generation for the future
the mondavi booth if a picture of us
would hang here someday what a fantastic
idea that is find a foster home for now
they just hope their game is a hit and
that someday people will look back on it
as a classic to